my advocacy
narrative was
whatever you want to build it already
exists so let's find someone who's built
it let's test it let's understand if
it's going to give you the value you
think it's going to give you and then we
can decide if we want to scale it or we
can bend after go do our own thing and
close ourselves from scratch
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
this episode is powered by jay ventures
a community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders today i'm
joined by sandiso sibisi open innovation
studio director of kui studios
sandiso is an innovator and entrepreneur
with over 10 years of experience in
technology consulting she is the former
head of open innovation of africa at
accenture and has led tech
implementations data strategy cost
reductions assignments in the consumer
goods sector
she is the founder of kui studios an
innovation lab for corporations amongst
other accolades she is a sustainable
development goals ambassador mizani's
100 inspiring and aspiring leaders a
player part ambassador with bram south
africa and inspiring 50 women in tech
and a mandela washington fellow welcome
sandiso
sandy sosibisi welcome to 20 minute
leaders from johannesburg right
yes thank you called johannes right now
well i'm in very hot tel aviv and so i
think we're balancing it out and and
it's a it's really great to have you
here uh cindy so i think that you're
working is
is really really interesting your
journey is very very interesting and i'm
excited to hear all about it and all
about the positive impact you've made
today you're open innovation studio
director for kui studios and open
innovation studio lab you're the founder
of born to succeed helping women a as a
nonprofit i believe helping over 120
women really amazing you're also the
open innovation africa lead for
accenture among amongst
other incredible positions and so
a lot to talk about all the way from
africa as an ecosystem to women
empowerment to innovation with
corporates and really really tackling
some amazing amazing problems so
sandisto how do we get started about
where you came from and how you began
your journey into the tech ecosystem
so i have uh
i'm actually from a very small town but
i think i'm a big city girl now i cannot
imagine myself in a small town anymore
richard's bay was it's cool and then i
went on to uh for chapston high school
that's an another like positive natal
another province in the country
um and then i moved on to my university
was how dang how dang is the province
where jaina's burgers i did my varsity
there university i did a bachelor of
commerce but focusing on i.t so i did a
little bit of coding and lots and lots
around systems
and then after that i did um and then i
joined accenture actually um but in my
last year of my studies accenture was
actually my sponsor they gave me a
scholarship to complete my last year
um when i joined them thereafter um so
yeah i started with i was mentored by
them at least in my last year of work so
when it came to like the interviews i
think i i did pretty well because i
hadn't been talking for a whole year
that was very helpful um and accenture
what did i do there so i did lots of
work in consumer goods um
a lot
sap millers for my clients tiger brands
another
fmcg in south africa um i did some work
in financial services as well
and then i moved on from there to do um
yeah and then i mean in that time i did
lots of like generic like technology
consulting
but i always knew i had a greater
purpose so i wanted to help young girls
and then i started the bones succeed
foundation as like a side gig after work
sort of thing
and helped a lot of girls get employed
educate them around employment and then
from there i moved on and i did
development work at accenture with
accenture development partnerships and i
think for me that was where i actually
learned about you know running a
business or you know doing really i'm
senior level sort of work because adp
extension development partnerships
allows you to be um to be your own boss
as such you create your own business
line your own structures and everything
and i learned that and then after that
and then i was ahead of open innovation
for the african continent
very exciting role very very challenging
innovation in any corporate even if it's
a consultancy just like the most
challenging thing and yeah and that's
that's basically my humble beginning
tell me about accenture
sponsoring your last year of university
how how did that come about
oh um so i'd actually applied to
accenture
like to before i finish my honors my
fourth year so in this in south africa
you can actually get a job with the
three-year qualification as opposed to
other countries so i actually applied
and they actually declined my
application but i was so determined to
work for the best technology consultancy
i was like i'm not going to work for
anyone else even though i had other
offers
and just by fluke i came across and my
parents had told me that um
we don't have any more money to pay for
university so they just paid for the
first three years and and then i know
when i was looking for a scholarship i
came across the accenture one and then i
applied and then i got it literally
that's how i got it and so within
accenture
you're the open innovation africa lead
and you're bridging the gap between
innovative products developed by
startups and the needs of accenture's
corporate clients
now
is this specifically in africa is this
globally with accenture what does it
mean to be the open innovation africa
lead
um i wish uh like i i i was this role
i i wish i knew what i know now when i
started
um and i think it's because
we're building the role as we go along
but primarily it meant that
i had to encourage the business
accenture people consultants
and our clients to not build products
from scratch
um there's a tendency to want to build
stuff from scratch but my advocacy
narrative was
whatever you want to build it already
exists so let's find someone who's built
it let's test it let's understand if
it's going to give you the value you
think it's going to give you and then we
can decide if we want to scale it or we
can bend after go do our own thing and
build ourselves from scratch that was
like what i was trying to do
like i said very challenging you know
the
corporates are very skeptical about
working with startups you know putting
trust in startups so i mean half the
time i spent explaining how capable a
startup was not just not the client
problem but rather the capability of
another nerve as opposed to actually
shaping the solution now one of the
things that i'm always really excited
and inspired in this show is hearing
about the positive impact that leaders
are making in their own communities and
with born to succeed
over the last eight years you're working
with women with young unemployed women
in south africa
and helping hundreds of women so far
tell me a little bit about what led you
to starboard to succeed how how you know
you're even thinking strategically about
running this program
yeah so i think at that time when i
started it wasn't even a stretch to do
just like just the desire to want to do
more for the country you know just
having a normal job wasn't enough for me
i know consulting with a normal job but
like i wanted to just do more than
individuals
um and in africa i built i built it
based on a response to the high
unemployment rate
um and specifically around young girls
so what i wanted to do was help them
transition from unemployment into work
so i used to lobby for them so go speak
to corpus and say you've got like five
girls could you consider them for an
internship give them work experience for
three months
um i will find another donor to pay the
internship but you just have them in the
workplace and let's get them experienced
i'm also just negotiating a lot of young
girls get into financial difficulties at
a young age they open credit cards they
can't manage and therefore if you're
blacklisted you actually can't work for
a financial services institution so my
role was to go and say you know um we
have trained uh these 10 girls on
financial literacy and now they have a
better understanding of how to manage
finances although they were blacklisted
we have taken them through a program and
put an intervention for them to know
better so could you give them a chance
and we'll continue to mentor them and
you saw that you know the the the the
the
i guess the desire of corpus to come on
board and then actually give those goals
a chance so that was basically my role
for 16 very very cool and you know
as you're continuing with with with born
to succeed and you're talking you're
thinking more more critically and more
strategically about
about the unemployment of young women in
south africa and where the ecosystem is
heading what did you learn
tangibly as a leader throughout this
initiative whether it be personal
lessons for you
professional lessons that that young
women across south africa can can
already you know put to good use other
leaders of nonprofits can can leverage
um i think i learned how to um
ask for money
when you have an ngo you have to like
kind of do that every day and you need
to not be shy about it you're not asking
somebody to give you a loan to buy a
pair of shoes you're asking somebody for
money to give a person an opportunity of
livelihood
so i think you need to be like bullish
about that and ask people for money so i
got very used to asking people for money
um and i i think i've became a very good
fundraiser because my team would then
just carry out the work i had a lot of
volunteers on my team so that was
probably the biggest lesson i learned
and i mean 10 years later i have my own
enterprise i'm not necessarily asking
for money but i'm selling a proposition
that cooi's going to offer a specific
company and so i'm able to sell and ask
them to bank on us and trust us to
deliver the work for them so i think
that those that time i'd want to succeed
set the very foundation that i needed to
learn to actually start my own business
and i guess also just being resourceful
right so ngos don't have a lot of money
so you just learn to to make do with
what you have actually and i think i'm
running my startup in a similar manner
we run on a very you know um we're very
uh pedantic about costs and we try and
save every penny so i'm applying those
principles very very cool and so let's
transition more to to innovation and kui
studios and and how you're thinking
through
rapid prototyping corporates
i guess there is
some things that are similar in nature
to your work with accenture right
yeah so actually i i built
after the experience i had at accenture
i think exchange i learned a lot right
um but excited is a really big
organization that does you know
hundreds of things you know um
open innovation was just like one of
them so you can imagine in the in the in
the pyramid how far down you are in the
line and also it being new
so um when i left accenture i decided to
open my my own studio actually not work
for another uh
house that or consultancy
um and and that's how i transitioned
into curry studios i wanted to do more
of what i was doing at accenture but
fully just like a hundred percent on
that and i think i was also at the stage
where it was just time to just start my
own thing and although i had won't
succeed once that siddhartha was a soft
landing it was social entrepreneurship
and i think there was a great according
on my life
to actually be a full-time entrepreneur
and just trust that god is going to
provide for my every need and
i mean he's been so wonderful i'm so
lucky like to have this enterprise i
mean we're only like two and a half
years old and i think really really well
um we have about four um large clients
as an organization which i think is
brilliant for forgiven also that we
started a year before covert right
so i'm very proud of what me and the
team have achieved and i'm looking
forward to doing so so much more with
what we've also made very very cool tell
me a little bit about your experience
now working you know with corporates and
innovation over the last two and a half
years what what does that mean like for
you
so actually are they more um open to it
i think it's
by and large because um a lot of
corporates are strapped for cash trying
to do things in a you know like
economical manner so
with exchange i didn't have the
flexibility to do things a hundred
percent my way because you're working
within a corporate environment whereas
at kui i'm able to look at things
differently and negotiate with clients
and find various pricing models that
actually work for them and their
financial constraints but also i'm able
to do what i love so i think that would
that's been like quite surprising our i
would say in the first year though you
know it's there's a lot of waiting that
nobody told me about so um eventually my
friend um he's been an entrepreneur for
a while he said you're gonna get drive
yourself crazy waiting for for the
client to respond to your email so just
go and study like find the degree to
study so then i signed up for a master's
in innovation studies advanced
university and i'm currently finishing
my dissertation right now but that was
sort of like so much just because i need
the education but it was like just
something to keep me busy but it was
strategic as well because i i did a
masters in innovation studies so i was
currently studying what i'm actually
working on and also if you think about
my peers and my my classmates were all
looking to join the innovation space in
business innovation space so just my my
corporate network as well also grew from
that opportunity so i'm very lucky that
i'm doing my masters in actual
innovation studies what i'm currently
working on and also building a business
and innovation so i think i've just got
the best of both worlds i just am
crossing my fingers now to just finish
my dissertation which is so hard
where do you see your personal growth
the most
in the last few years as you're
understanding corporates better and
you're working with corporates
i think
patience is probably the biggest
lesson i've learned i think uh
as young people i think we're quite
impatient
um
it's not i mean it's just i guess our
nature won things yesterday it's this
whole instant gratification thing i've
had to learn to be patient
um and to not pursue things because
they're going to give me some sort of
instant gratification but rather do the
long the long journey you know so it's
always funny when i meet a client and my
team and we have a great conversation so
my team is like okay so when are we
signing the deal i'm like oh my gosh if
we spoke to them today prepare yourself
for a six to nine month sales journey
and and people don't understand that
they think that if you
meet someone today you'll sell a deal
today but it takes time i mean when we
when we got nestle as a client it took
about probably almost 12 months to to
close that deal
um but that's just you know um
the sales game it's a long journey so
that makes a lot of sense you know
100 and
and you know i think that
understanding
the the mindset it's not just about how
to sell it and understand even the value
proposition for the corporates but it's
also understanding the mindset
understanding the importance of
relationship building and everything
that comes in between now i want to take
you back a little bit to your childhood
um before accenture before university
and you said you came from a small
village what what did you what were you
really fascinated by as a child as you
were sort of roaming the world
so my parents are very entrepreneurial
my mom was a newest full-time but she
also did wedding cakes after hours the
catering for events
my dad was a videographer so you take
videos of people's weddings and uh
birthday parties but he wasn't a
full-time job as an hr director
so
i think my parents just always just
showed me that you need to have i said i
think two sources of income so i learned
the entrepreneurial spirits through them
like just going above and beyond the
cold not just relying on one chick
um and so that was probably the
foundation and i think growing up my
parents uh were very strict on like
conduct
um so that's that i guess that's helped
me be disciplined as i grow
finish what you started so or having to
finish the plate on the food i know it's
a small lesson but if you teach your
child to finish the plate on the food
you're teaching them how to you know
finish what you started
um
and then and and obviously as people are
dishing up the food you say to the
person that's enough
that's not food for me but if you don't
say it in time and you ask for more and
more and more you must finish that place
because you ask for that place and don't
waste that food so i think i'm i'm i'm
very big on finishing what i started i
think that speaks to my discipline
i was very intrigued by computers
my dad bought us a secondhand computer
from work in 1994
so when i got it it was a desktop you
know
it it was i think it was ms-dos and then
when a year later windows 95 came and
then we were like on it you know um and
then and then we've got the internet
shortly the
the telephone connection one that used
to go
like make those poison so i remember all
of those i just like just intrigued by
computers and i remember i used to be
obsessed about the spice girls so the
spice girls remember back in the day we
had this thing called like chat rooms
yes and you could like join in and like
wait for a celebrity to come on so i
used to like stay and wait for the spy
schools to come on so i've just always
been interested in just like what the
computer could do uh we used to have a
like a
people's birthday cards just silly at
home and stuff like that so i've just
always been into computers i guess and
then that's how i kind of listened into
doing my information systems
qualifications very very cool and if and
today
what really inspires you in your day
i think it's my team currently um you
know because we've built a team that i
think is is going to pave the the way
forward for cooling studios people that
are eager to to learn eager to grow
once more for themselves i'm very
excited with what the work we're doing
right now and just their dedication
um i think they inspire me and i wanna
like make them proud by selling the work
so we can deliver the great work do
their great work so that's pretty
exciting so i'm and just developing
young people um you know part of my work
is obviously finding startups that can
help corporate solve their problems so
i'm also helping entrepreneurs you know
um meet their targets and meet their
goals and grow as well so you know if
you look at my life it's very clear that
i i've always just been a connector of
you know higher level to lower level
people
finding ways how they can work together
and and then you know reading value from
that so i think that's always been my
role and um
i didn't want to succeed i'm doing it at
cooney studios and so i'm very excited
with like how
like all of the dots are connecting my
favorite um like commencement speeches
with steve jobs one that's connects the
dots you know so i feel like life is the
dots are excellent i love it i love it
thank you sandy so and what are three
words that you use to describe yourself
i'm a lot of fun i know i don't like it
because i work so hard but i'm actually
a lot of fun my friends and i actually
my friends and i went to maldives just
like couple of months ago had the time
of our lives so very very happy
um a lot of fun i'm very very spiritual
extremely extremely spiritual
um and
and i just want to like i want to leave
a mark on this earth i don't know if i
so it's probably fine spiritual and
which means i want to leave like
so thank you so much this was fantastic
thank you for the great work that you're
doing thank you for the inspiration and
this was really great i enjoyed it and
stay safe and stay healthy thank you
thank you bye